l'ambassadeur des états unis vient donc
d'arriver au ministère des affaires
étrangères russe pour livrer sa fameuse
réponse écrite à moscou au sujet de
l'affairé craignent n des représentants
russes ukrainiens allemands et français
sont réunis en format normandie à paris
et c'est une première depuis plus de six
mois on attend une allocation une
allocution d antony blinken le chef de
la diplomatie américaine qui devrait
donc intervenir assez vite et on
retrouve tout de suite gulliver craag à
kiev notre correspondant gulliver
bonsoir la réaction peut être justement
des ukrainiens alors qu'on sait
maintenant que et bien un ambassadeur
américain a déposé une note écrite à
moscou
on vient juste de l'apprendre et manon
on attend la réaction des russes à ces
documents on ignore le contenu de ces
documents plus ou moins peut-être que
anthony blinken dont peu de temps va
nous en dire plus mais pour l'ukraine
beaucoup dépend probablement de la
réaction de moscou à cette réponse
écrite leur demande pour le moment je ne
peux pas dire que l'attitude des
ukrainiens et changer vraiment depuis ce
qu'elle est depuis plusieurs jours les
ukrainiens reste plus ou moins calme
même si certaines personnes s'inquiètent
mais le gouvernement multiplie les
appels au calme et laisse comprendre que
il s'inquiète beaucoup pour l'économie
du pays et qu'il est très important
justement de garder le calme de ne pas
paniquer à cause des effets
catastrophiques qu une panique
généralisée pourrait avoir sur
l'économie et gulliver que pense-t-il
justement côté ukrainien que de ce
format normandie auxquelles justement
participent les ukrainiens les allemands
les français et les russes ça faisait
longtemps que ce format n'avait pas été
mis en place
les attentes ne sont pas vraiment grande
en ukraine dans l'opinion publique que
puisque on comprend bien que le
processus de minsk que si vous voulez et
à une impasse puisque l'interprétation
de l'ukraine cloche de ce document je
veux dire cloche absolument avec
l'interprétation de la russie la russie
voudrait que des élections soient tenues
dans la partie d'une base qui est
occupée par les forces qu'elles
contrôlent avant qu'elle ne retire
qu'elle ne rende le contrôle de la
frontière à l'ukraine donc qu'elle ne
permette à l'ukraine de contrôler le
flux des armes l'ukraine refuse
absolument de tenir des élections dans
de telles circonstances ce qui
reviendrait selon kiev a donné plus ou
moins à la russie la possibilité
d'établir son contrôle sur ces régions
plus ou moins officiellement et d'avoir
des régions soit disant des régions
autonomes de l'ukraine ni qui seraient
en réalité des régions contrôlées par la
russie officiellement avec eu un droit
de veto sur les décisions de l'ukraine
c'est les ukrainiens l'ont répété
plusieurs fois par quelque chose qu'ils
sont prêts à accepter leur
interprétation du document de minsk qui
est le sujet de discussion dans le
format normandie est tout autre merci
beaucoup d'univers gulliver craag en
direct de kiev